are you a progressive Democrat I'm a
liberal I think that liberals care about
the little guy liberals care about
social justice what why do so many
Democrats who are liberal or progressive
why do they seem so hostile to the two
they just the idea of school choice
because it seems very much to speak
exactly to those issues they've been
captured by the special interests and
and you know the teachers union is
really about the teachers union it's
about the perpetuation of Union hegemony
the former history professor public
school teacher in New York City
politician Eva Moskowitz has become one
of the highest profile figures in the
education reform movement featured
everywhere from Glamour magazine's to
the New York Times teacher union leaders
who correctly view her as an enormous
threat to their power are fighting to
combat her growing influence Moskowitz
is the founder and CEO of Success
Academy New York City's largest charter
school network these are public schools
funded by taxpayers and operate
independently from the city's Department
of Education the teachers here don't
belong to a union and they don't have
tenure so the school can reward them
with higher salaries or fire them if
they're not meeting expectations and
Success Academy students and parents
choose to apply here instead of simply
attending the district schools to which
they're sent based on where they live
attracting students hasn't been a
problem with 32 schools spread around
New York City Success Academy posted
test results last year that astounded
education policy experts meanwhile
Moskowitz and our allies have been
building a powerful coalition to counter
the outsized political influence of
organized labor in the education world
many people just want to know how her
schools are performing so well and what
are you doing that other people are not
one of the fundamental differences
between us and other schools is the
level of rigor that we have so it's what
does happen what kids are being asked to
do now in third grade we think kids can
do that in kindergarten in 1st grade we
are
vehicle about reading the amount the
quality of the books we read in school
we read at home I think people have
forgotten that that is one of the tools
in our tool kits simply the amount of
time that kids are spending on reading
and being super engaged in reading that
alone can change outcomes what's a
typical student I mean or give a kind of
demographic background of you know where
where they come so the vast majority of
our kids are black and brown the vast
majority of our kids are living below
the poverty line about 15% of our kids
are special needs to get accepted at
Success Academy students enter a random
lottery this year about 18,000 kids
applied and fewer than 20% won a spot
the nail-biting process that families go
through when trying to get their kids
into a Success Academy school was
chronicled in a 2010 feature-length
documentary called the lottery if you
could would you take in all 18,000 oh
yeah
what to hold you back from doing that I
mean the the pushback is pretty intense
not only do we have elected officials
opposing this work but the bureaucracy
impedes us at every turn it's very hard
to open schools Moskowitz his biggest
battle on that front happened earlier
this year when the newly elected mayor
of New York City bill de blasio denied
Success Academy promised space in
existing school buildings so that it
could open new branches the move was
rooted in a political rivalry between de
Blasio and Moskowitz that goes back to
their days serving together in the New
York City Council more than a decade ago
at a Teachers Union sponsored event
during the mayoral race
de Blasio told the crowd it's time for
Eva Moskowitz to stop having the run of
the place just to stop being tolerated
enabled supported Moskowitz and our
allies countered by busing 11,000
charter school parents and kids up to
the state capital in Albany to protests
and New York State Governor Andrew Cuomo
came out in support
here today to tell you that we stand
with you you are not alone
we will save charter schools de Blasio
retreated Success Academy could move
forward with its expansion plans after
all in state lawmakers quickly passed a
bill to protect charter schools from
future interference by the mayor
several months later Moskowitz and her
school choice allies again flex their
political muscle by bringing out more
than 20,000 supporters for a rally in
lower Manhattan this time to draw
attention to all the traditional public
schools that are underperforming the
system is really it's sort of like the
dinosaurs it's this very antiquated way
of doing things if you want to change
anything in the New York City school
system and this is true for urban
America the mayor of the city of New
York and the head of the labor union has
to agree on every single change to the
New York City school system that is a
very difficult that's a very aside
that's a very old-fashioned way of doing
things we find in our world we have to
be nimble we have to sometimes lengthen
the school day we have to make a change
we have to adjust to the empirical
reality that we're seeing where does it
go wrong because one assumes good faith
on the part of you know both teachers
and the union that represents them they
want to educate kids right so where
where does where does stuff go wrong the
bureaucracy has a kind of civil servant
imprint and so it's slow its
unresponsive and again there are good
people who are there it's just the
system as a whole is very ossified the
contract is complex and voluminous it
uses a terminology recall rights
incumbent rights retention rights
Moskowitz first began speaking out about
the corrosive influence of unions on
public schools back in November of 2003
when she held hearings in the New York
City Council to bring attention to labor
contracts and the inane work rules they
impose we must examine these rules and
discuss them New Yorkers
must know what the rules are and come to
conclusions she even went toe-to-toe
with the powerful head of the New York
City Teachers Union I want to take this
opportunity to welcome Randi Weingarten
the President of the United Federation
of Teachers that is what the UFT has
been trying to get across this year the
issue of helping us supporting us to
help every single child in our charge is
it the case or is it not the case that
it principal could have to accept a
candidate sight unseen there is a plan
that was negotiated starting in the
mid-60s between the Department answer my
question UFT just it is it the case that
a principle under any circumstance could
have to take a candidate without ever
having interviewed that yes or no yes
thank you her colleagues were horrified
and did all they could to deflect
Moskowitz's questions and to defend the
Union entire statewide system that's the
system that you have you must work
within it I looked at the teachers union
contract I looked at the custodians
union contract I looked at the
principal's union contract and I was
told that you know I would be kicked out
of office and possibly my chairmanship
would be taken away and all sorts of
things like this but I thought that I
had an obligation to look under the hood
and there's some crazy stuff in there
given exams in New York City there's
something called the ten foot rule which
means that the custodian can paint up to
ten feet but the painters Union gets to
paint above ten feet and this is still
enforced this is still enforced this was
negotiated last in 1965 and it still
holds and what ends up happening is you
have the painters Union and the
custodians Union in constant arbitration
fighting about it and for the children
this mop or sweeper distinction means
that it's hard to find a fully painted
classroom teachers do not have to work
the lunchroom
it's very hard to run a lunchroom with
500 kids without adults who know and are
highly skilled at supervising so when
you gave away that little work rule you
actually affected schools and brought
chaos into schools and there are
hundreds of those work rules at the 2003
hearings bill de blasio who at the time
was a city council member from Brooklyn
defended the union work rules and I
think management everywhere on earth
deals with rules and I'm not saying
every rule was perfect by any stretch
but management everywhere on earth deals
with rules and other contexts and good
managers find a way to get the most out
of people in those hearings I mean you
had future mayor de Blasio defending the
teachers union defending the existing
work rules you know where is that coming
from
Bill's position was kind of the norm
which is you don't take on the teachers
union you don't look at the contract
that the head of the teachers union said
to me very clearly we will take you out
and true to their word in 2005 when
Moskowitz made a run for Manhattan
borough president the teachers union
mobilized against her and she lost in
the primary which at least for the time
being ended her political career but you
know I'm a big girl I knew that that was
a risk and I decided that it was you
know sometimes you know I think
politicians are very used to deferring
when they're going to be honest and sort
of continually postponing working on the
issues that matter I I felt that you
know it it was just my job to look at
the issues that I effected teaching and
learning and if that meant that I could
no longer be an elected official so be
it so instead of working to reform the
system from within Moskowitz left
politics to build an alternative to the
traditional public schools you think
your model is replicable or how much of
it revolves around you this seems to be
a problem with education
often that you know there's a particular
person who kind of creates a model and
then as that person either fades out of
a situation or whatever things fall
apart I don't think the district is
scalable mm-hmm so I think the question
we should be it's actually we have proof
right at least in New York City that the
scaling didn't work very well right
right
we've got in New York State we've close
to a million kids who failed the test
I don't know under what measure that
could be a successful scaling experience
so maybe the model is not one giant
system maybe the model is lots of social
entrepreneurs who have school districts
of varying sizes you know that's why I
support everything from tax credits to
charters to you know bold district
reform you know we got to try a bunch of
things and we need to see if we can get
real talent into the space critics of
charters argue that schools like Success
Academy are excelling in part because
they serve kids that come from more
stable homes with more involved parents
than their public school counterparts
those parents that are willing to take
the effort to enter their kids into a
lottery critics say or more likely to
have children who are motivated to get
ahead is there a difference between the
parents who decide to go into a lottery
so you know 18,000 kids are apply for
your spaces are the parents of those
18,000 kids somehow radically different
than you know the parents who either
don't care don't know about lack of a
school I this is sort of an unknowable
question but I spend an enormous amount
of time with parents I did before I open
the first school as an elected official
going to communities I did more parent
PTA meetings hundreds and hundreds of
meetings and I have met very few parents
who do not deeply deeply love and care
for their children
I think it's on the school to educate
and do outreach to parents we get
criticized a lot for marketing and we
mark it because we want to make sure
that parents understand the value of
what they're getting success academies
critics also claim that the school
pushes out struggling kids at a recent
union protest reason TV caught up with
Michael Mulgrew who succeeded Randi
Weingarten as the head of New York
City's teachers you when miss Moskowitz
serves all children and stop having such
very high rates of what we call
disappearing students then I'll be more
than happy to talk with it but first do
what we do and serve the same children
we do there is a fair amount of
attrition in your school actually that's
inaccurate attrition is extremely low
both compared to the district and
compared to our co-located schools okay
so but I mean typically if you have a
hundred students in first grade how many
will be inside we we lose about ten
percent a year okay
the district loses about twenty percent
a year and some of our co-located slews
between thirty and forty okay so it's
not that there is an attrition but that
when it's it's relative to the other
populations it's actually correct and
also we're educating kids for longer
mmm-hmm so an elementary school in a
district goes k-25 we're educating kids
K to eight one of the standard
complaints against you as a person is
that you made over half of half a
million dollars last year or you do does
that matter well I think it does matter
and I think we have to we have to invest
in talent we pay our teachers more than
the district we pay our principals more
we pay at the home office more we've got
to attract talent as much talent as
humanly possible into the sector and I
think if you want talent you know you're
gonna have to reward people not as much
as you know
an investment banker can make on Wall
Street but I don't think because one is
doing public education that that
necessarily means that one is worth less
in terms of compensation are you hopeful
that public education will improve in in
New York City you know I I think it's
gonna take really the citizens of New
York deciding that they've had enough of
educational failure I am very hopeful
though that the public and parents are
going to demand a change I think it's
just it's unsustainable to spend this
much money to get so few great results I
just don't think you can go on forever
like that and I think the reason there
hasn't been more outcry is because
before charters there were no
alternatives now I think people are
seeing that there between parochial
schools and charter schools and moving
out of New York and doing all these
things parents are voting with their
feet one way or another and I think
that's going to change things